guys say is a high body count hi just
give me give me a number twenty five
twenty could we say 20 is high yeah okay
that's like medium high yeah um okay so
let's say he's really high okay so let's
say 25 yeah okay her body counts 25.
um however she's never she's never okay
she's never gone back to an ex ever
or you can date a girl that's had five
but there's one X she's been sleeping
with on and off
for seven years that's a good question
on every relationship that ends that's
the guy she goes back to oh yeah she's
done she's helpful we did no which would
you pick which would I pick yeah I know
and please don't say neither you got to
pick one it's only fun this way
tell me the first one again so she's 20
she has her body counts 25 yeah
um again the all things equal looks
everything else is equal one girl's body
counts 25 she's never gone back to an ex
the other girl's body count is five
I'm picking the X I'm picking I'm
picking the one with 25. 25 yeah that's
wild really yeah so you would pick the X
yeah because I mean I'll tell you why
yeah if she keeps going back to the same
guy she's kept going back to the same
guy after the breakup yeah yeah if she
keeps doing that um is it only after the
breakup where she's been is a funny
business going in between
um you don't know this is just bro you
know there has to be an emotion if I
actually believe
that she's only going off but back to
that X after the breakups yeah then I'll
go with the one with five and the
boyfriend 100 25 guys or more but but I
would have to really trust her yeah I I
don't know why
fam I feel like I feel like I feel like
I would recommend the one I don't think
I'd recommend it yeah yeah I'll get rid
of both for them to be fair but like but
I feel like if that's you I feel like
the one that's more dangerous is the one
that keeps like the situation there's a
situationship for six years yeah it'll
be on my mind that's why I said that but
I'm saying if we've built up that level
of trust if we've spoken about it and I
you know I I don't trust it I hardly
trust anybody to be honest wow so why
because
when a richer anyway so so no but like I
would I'll choose if we've got a certain
level of trust and also part of me would
believe that like you know I you know
I'd re-alph a widower
that would be my my Outlook anyway I
might not be right but I wouldn't be
threatened by the way
what if he was Michael B Jordan
[Laughter]
is because he chose Laurie Harvey yeah
right and Lori Harvey had been passed
around the industry
but the thing is his choice in women is
skewed yeah he's got he doesn't know
he's doing yeah
one thing I just want to say between the
two women that you described for me the
analysis is actually one of them is
actually a tester and the other one is
an investor the the strategy some yeah
it goes back to pick up Artistry but the
women have personality types some women
are testers and some women are investors
some women go out with multiple men just
to find the one that is the closest to
the one that the ideal their ideal man
whilst other men other women go out with
one guy and invest in him in order to
make him the guy that they actually want
and the first one with the five and
keeps going back to the old ex-girl
boyfriend is the investor type who is
trying to get this guy to become the one
that she wanted whilst a woman with 2025
plus she's a tester she'll test you out
if the next guy comes your monkey branch
and and you so so to make it clear I
picked the right one
yo
false let's just say I want to thank
everyone for coming through we have been
on air for a couple of hours now you
know we've already had one person leave
um it was too late I'd like to say she
didn't like she didn't Pearl Castle
herself oh is that a new one now Pearl
Castle I've never I've never done it but
you never know it could be I've been
getting less patient lately Pearl Castle
that might be a thing
um but yeah thank you all for coming
um
to show up now
um before we do wrap the shop can I just
get everybody's final thoughts on the
subject we'll start over there
um as I said yeah I don't have any final
thoughts I think I've given quite a
descriptive my thoughts in quite detail
throughout the show
um yeah thanks for having me no problem
thank you
um yeah can I just plug yeah I've just
reached a thousand subscribers on power
on shmbly so go there and find me there
what's that it's my YouTube channel
and also I'm on Twitter and I don't have
Instagram yet uh but as far as the final
thoughts are concerned men who are the
average guy pretty much I I think I fit
the mold on that
um yes do look elsewhere unfortunately
the West has has done is gone it's it's
a lost cause Western women whether you
think their their trades or not they are
feminists no matter what they say to you
feminism is the cancer that has already
seeped into the West it's a lost cause
go to Southeast Asia or or the Middle
East I thought you said you didn't
struggle here you said in your no no no
no no for marriage sorry sorry for
marriage for Pump and dumps Europe is
your golden ticket
all day every day feminism is the
greatest thing that happened to a man
who wants to get laid
Yeah Yeah but but if you want to get
married look elsewhere because I think
Europe is done I'm sorry yeah
um my final thoughts I would say ladies
if you are not a very and you're a
single mother do not go and curl up in a
quarter and die
you don't have to pump and don't miss
them
you know no you're worth but it's been
it's been amazing it's been really
insightful it's been really good like
hearing who hurt your opinions
yeah that that's my final thought
okay um final folks I think I think
ultimately women in the west are
brought up differently to women in other
countries as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible